hallo leute und komm zurück bei kali
antwortet heute eine ganz besondere
episode bei der internen weihnachtsfeier
hier in berlin
wir haben bei facebook leute eingeladen
unsere zuschauer und guckt mal
italienisch zeigt mal wie viele leute
gekommen sind
aus aller welt zum beispiel ist anders
hier hallo hallo karree an das ist
eigentlich nicht mehr zu kommen denn er
macht ein praktikum bei uns aber er hat
heute gekocht was hast du gekocht
das ist
das gericht aus indonesien ein typisches
indonesisches gericht und hier sind
leute aus aller welt aus ganz vielen
verschiedenen ländern
und es gibt gutes essen und wir werden
heute etwas besonderes machen wir werden
ein paar kommentare vorlesen aber auch
fragen beantworten
sozusagen live aus der community
handelst du hast eine frage ja ich habe
eine frage hoffentlich oder unhöflich
wenn man die nase rümpft die nase machen
lassen
wer beim essen bei weitem erkennt das
naseputzen mit einem taschentuch und das
ist vielen leuten schon in deutschland
aufgefallen die deutschen machen dass
beim essen oder jaja der vw familie ist
indonesien das ist ganz in der nähe sein
ist das unhöflich in vielen anderen
ländern auch bei uns eigentlich auch
aber in deutschland das ist nicht so und
deswegen machen dass viele wie einfach
das auch manchmal
[Musik]
tut mir leid kein problem
okay wir werden jetzt nur einige fragen
vorlesen als erstes world golf hall oled
kannst du mal hierhin kommen mal gold
bewegt sich immer langsam
so wie bei super easy german ok world
ich habe einige kommentare okay wir
lesen kommentare vor
ok kommentare zu wolz super easy jet
wörtlich jan-felix schreibt die secude
ismail ist everything ist es alles alles
in der welt war okay ich habe keinen
kein kommentar wieder lächeln
bis alles alles alles besessen hat gft
mft m schreibt yours so incredible and
fun i knew that you really happy metal
zu deutsch lernen und gut deutsch können
ja ja ja das freut mich leute und es ist
eigentlich okay andrä ag schreibt mehr
videos mit voltaire ist wirklich lustig
supermacht danke danke danke andrea
ja ja wir können mehr videos machen
machen noch ein video für andrea okay
und nun ist listening anfahrt schreibt
rita vitt ja das macht es so viel sinn
aber okay das ist seine meinung
rosa mag er beschreibt 000 ries vom
double double
wer ist rein reeves heißt weiß ich auch
nicht
ich dachte du weißt nein es wurde das
gut
ich glaube das ist ein fehler
israel is where is life service und drei
mails schreibt uns mit fans die dich
auch noch ein kommentar für dich die
welt schreibt die geißbock hennes low e
mobil speaking records ja stimmt wir
können sehr sehr langsam sprechen
super easy german malt redet immer so
langsam ich auch wenn ich wollte sehen
danke danke hürde des falls woher kommst
du ja ich komme aus brasilien aus
südamerika ja und ich bin hast du eine
frage zusammen
eigentlich habe ich ein kommentar ist
finde ich sie dir ganz ganz toll
alle diese interviews auf den straße mit
dem leute und diese tolle philosophische
fragen dass die janisch
den leuten stellen janosch wenn ich bin
ja mit fand das stimmt gut gemacht ja
noch gut gemacht weiter so ja hier ist
unsere polnische ecke die polen sind ja
immer gerne unter sich wir haben hier
drei toren und eine ukrainerin aber wir
sprechen aber wir versuchen das heißt
wir strecken nicht bis zum april zogen
die hat wo bist du heute hergekommen
weitergekommen hamburg ist nun gefallen
mit dem bus extrazug us es extra aus
hamburg kommt um heute abend uns
besuchen
das ist eine große ehre für uns und wo
seid ihr hergekommen
wir kommen aus zu wie z
hiervon in china aber wir haben erst
später gekommen als ihr seid jetzt aus
polen gefahren
warum heute mit uns zu feiern die kinder
wir lieben ist sehr zu empfehlen
ihr seid so toll dafür muss ich euch
umarmen sie sind extra aus polen
gekommen um unter diesem sinn hast du
eine frage
palina wir sind jetzt klare live hier in
bei youtube hast du eine frage an eine
deutsche ja aber vielleicht kannst du
uns in slubice besuchen
die ecken zu lernen internat und so
weiter
also wir sollen euch besuchen in spitze
der gäste ist bei der grenze oder ja das
ist in der nähe von frankfurt oder
das ist eine gute idee denn wir wollen
bald nach polen fahren wir machen eine
tour durch polen hat ja schon erzählt
ich habe vergessen und ich freue mich
sehr
ja wir fahren demnächst mit unserem
easyjet hindurch coolen dann besuchen
wir euch ab gemacht
wo kommst du her ich komme aus der
ukraine aber er in berlin nicht wird aus
der ukraine geborene in berlin seit ein
monat was machst du in berlin
ja ich mir echt auf den deutschland
studieren
ich bin sehr gut
viel erfolg hast du eine frage hast du
auch eine frage egal die deutsche
strecke eine gute frage warum gibt es
drei artikel um die deutsche sprache
warum ist es ist schwer warum es nicht
nur eine und einfach das hab' ich mich
noch nie gefragt ein artikel wäre viel
einfacher aber wir haben drei jahre
schreist du waren wir drei artikel haben
ja weil deutsches die ursprüngliche
sprache zu englisch englisch hat sich
aus deutsch entwickelt und die älteren
sprachen waren noch sehr kompliziert
erst die modernen sprachen haben sich im
laufe der entwicklung vereinfacht
aber diese factory an dieser effekt
kompliziert empfinden wir als eine
bereicherung
die sprache ist schöner reicher
interessanter witziger also es ist
interessant aber drei artikel die
meisten von euch hassen drei artikel
jahres sagt es bereichert euer leben
denkt mal darüber nach wo kommt ihr her
ich komme aus den usa aus syrien auch
aus fulda sie hier seid habt ihr eine
frage über die deutsche sprache oder die
deutsche kultur
ja habe ich ich würde gern wissen feiert
die deutschen weihnachten am 24 dezember
oder 25
dezember sehr gute frage wir feiern
weihnachten am 24 in amerika funktionen
sie sind ja normalerweise aber manche
leute feiern auch am 24 was macht ihr am
am 24 wir treffen mit unserer familie
und essen sehr viel
derzeit genießen das machen wir doch
auch aber wir die geschenke am 25 die
bescherung auf deutschen findet bei uns
am 24
statt und bei euch am 25 wir müssen nur
einmal feiern
wir haben gerade besucher von halo
francesco
dass es von schiffen aus italien kommen
wir gehen an die tür grüßen ihm
das ist unsere eingangstür hier in
unserem büro ich gehe mal raus hallo
herr zetsche
wir sind live im video super wie geht es
dir super guten dir willkommen in
unserem büro hereinspaziert
es sind schon ein paar leute hier
jonathan woher kommst du schön dich
kennenzulernen
ja und zum ende lesen wir jetzt noch
kommentare vor zu unserer weihnachts
episode bzw
zum making biscuits kekse backen muss
klaus ihr erinnert euch klaus hat euch
die frage gestellt warum es enten und
pilze gibt
bei den aus sternchen zum
fix zu machen und wir wollen von euch
wissen was ist eure theorie und hier
sind jetzt eure kommentare also die
besten erstmal schreibt klingt
beschreibt zwei stunden und ihr habt den
schnaps nicht angerührt trauriger smiley
ja usa das denkst du derrick gibt
beschreibt es war einmal eine ente die
sehr einsam war und ich und melden sie
möchte mit allen anderen tieren
weihnachten feiern
aber diese ente hatte keine geschenke
für die anderen dann kommt
weihnachtsmann mit pilzen und er
versuchte die rente die welse zu geben
weil die anderen städten zu brauchten
aber die ente verweigerte die pilzen und
musste alleine bleiben also man muss
immer geschenke
genaugenommen pelze vom weihnachtsmann
akzeptieren und sich nicht beschweren
ja direkt dass meine sehr schöne theorie
warum enden und kind etwas mehr
einnahmen zu tun haben
jetzt kommt noch eine frage an
stimmungshit zu hören
mohammed mohamed schreibt warum hat
janisch gar nichts gesagt wenn ich janz
stimme höre fühle ich mich richtig in
der asse german episode ja nicht du bist
ein warmherziger man in der welt carlos
glück gehabt mit janis danke sehr das
war sehr nett von dir also jemand hatte
ein islamist
campos meta kuss ist ordentlich
forschungs die hier in the night campus
bringt der bachelor
back for dinner for dinner schreibt jim
monster auch eine nette theorie und
recht zu guter letzt griesmayr hat eine
verschwörungstheorie zum thema pilze und
weihnachten machen um social business
operations in batik friedens es wenn es
bei source of protein avenue trains for
rain and elsewhere cronin special forces
findet bei der government of the world
primarily located andere ice auf
grünland in löchern dax a huge fan of
christmas celebration of the world all
sorts of cultures rostock pakistaner
exchange pex gibt's das
neu ist das objekt in der workshops make
präsent des stalkings centers blockes so
nett die das mit free easy flying high
altitude living with around take 2 hat
du hast gewonnen und dann bewerten
die beste theorie
warum enten und pilzen zu weinen
das raus
zwar kam die antwort denn besucher zu
dieser woche ein bisschen besser
dann schickt uns eure fragen um die welt
in die konter ab
mit zur deutschen städten
tschüss
[Musik]
unser hobby
ja